hi guys
scifi recapped here
before we start
warning
spoilers ahead
today
i'm going to explain a 2020 chinese
fantasy and adventure movie
called soul snatcher the movie begins
with a little fox clinging onto the
brink of a cliff
seeing that fox is about to fall to
death a young boy pulls it up but
accidentally slips off the cliff
the fox attempts to help the kid but his
sharp claws scratch his hand instead
unfortunately the kid loses his grip and
plunges down the cliff the fox
immediately rushes down to help him but
he is not moving at all the fox is very
sad and a teardrop lands under the wound
on the kid's hand
500 years later in a tribe of fox
spirits in human forms all young fox
spirits gather and are going to take on
a quest to achieve immortality however
one of them 13 does not have a ticket
thus he is not allowed to get in
his friends even make fun of him because
of his incapability
a few moments later a nine-tailed fox
comes in and transforms into an old man
who is the chief of the tribe he
explains that the young fox spirits have
to acquire the elixir of souls which can
be found in targeted human bodies or
clemon in order to gain powers
several students managed to secure the
black elixir and one of them azie
was the best among them successfully
transforms into a five-tailed fox
after that the elder announces that next
month there will be an opportunity for
the young fox spirits to acquire the
white elixir of the soul which only
occurs only once in a thousand years
this white elixir allows the chosen fox
spirits to transform into a nine-tailed
fox which is the strongest fox in
history the students then gather around
a magic stone to be assigned the mission
out of nowhere 13 suddenly shows up and
joins the other students hoping that he
will be assigned a mission too he is
extremely happy when a lot is written on
his hands even if it is not as complete
as other students
after the ceremony the chief explains to
13 that he is destined to become a first
class or nine-tailed immortal fox and
returns to heaven
however he was joking as he later states
that 13 was found by the roadside
he adds that 13 has no immortal
background at all and must be careful if
he doesn't want to be transformed back
into his original form the old man then
hands over a knife to help him complete
his mission
13 then goes away to find his elixir
while stealing a talking stone or called
wuxi from him
because a lot of students have died
recently while pursuing their elixir the
elder asks a man to assist 13 as he is
not strong enough
long story short 13 arrives at a village
where young scholar zygin is looking for
a man in the painting he meets 13 and
asks the same question to him but is
ignored
wooksy informs him that the targeted
human or clemond who is keeping his
elixir is nearby and 13 starts looking
for him he comes across an old priest
was able to cure people from their
diseases
the old priest traps ghosts in paintings
and manages to cure kid by using blood
from one of his paintings
later 13 meets zygin again he's shocked
and accidentally kicked zaigeen's donkey
away causing it to run away
the donkey comes back and headbutts 13
bringing him with it and wrecking havoc
in the entire village while zaijin is
chasing after his donkey the old priest
secretly casts a protection spell
towards zygin's body in the middle of
the forest the donkey drops 13 and runs
away
zaigeen begs him to return a donkey but
he runs away and zygin chases after him
a few moments later both of them are
exhausted and arrive in an abandoned
temple
thirteen then realizes that zygin is his
clemon and figures out that he is going
to take an exam to become a government
official thus he becomes kind towards
him and promises that he will escort him
to the city
zygin explains that the man in the
painting is darren his elder brother and
the donkey's owner who also went to
complete the exam at night when 13 is
about to kill the clemont the guardian
who was assigned earlier to assist 13
appears and suggests him to lead the
clermont into a dangerous situation
where he will become hopeless or fearful
the next day the donkey which is
actually 13's guardian transforming into
it has been found and it makes the
scholar happy the unlikely duo builds up
their friendship as they become travel
companions
since then zygin calls his new friend
xiaobai
they eventually arrive at a misty and
quiet village where a lot of scholars
are preparing themselves for the
imperial examination
both of them decide to rest there for a
night
at night xiaobai is lured by a frog that
produces gold from its butt
zygin follows his path until he meets
the owner of the academy
suddenly he is attacked by a frog's
tongue and is brought to another
dimension
the sleepy zai gene is then welcomed by
a giant frog demon he tries to run away
and suddenly xiaobai arrives to help him
the frog even uses his power to blow
zaigen and zhao by away
they manage to hide but it doesn't take
a long time for the frog to spot them
the demon frog manages to capture
xiaobai and swallow him while the
scholar runs away
it turns out that xiaobai has been
working together with the frog to scare
him however the clemont comes back to
save his friend this time equipped
himself with a torch
the academy owner transforms himself
back to the demon frog whose tongue is
burned by him the frog uses his sucking
skill causing the torch to fly towards
his mouth and burn his entire mouth
xiaobai eventually is blasted out of its
mouth hitting the wall like an arrow to
the bull's eye while the wounded demon
frog is carried away by the baby frogs
long story short they continue their
journey by using a boat the guardian
suggests xiaobai to bring the zayajin to
xiakong city where there is a girl who
can reveal the color of the elixir the
clemont awakens causing the frog demon
to jump into the water and the guardians
to transform into donkeys xiaobai
reveals his true identity to him that he
is a fox spirit after he promises that
he won't eat him zygin comes out and
cures zhao by his wound
on the other side the frog helps them to
move the boat zygin shares a story about
darren telling that he is his role model
and xiaobai will help him to find darwin
they finally arrive at jiakong city
where a lot of beautiful ladies are
gathered
suddenly zygin is directed by a young
boy to an exclusive building where
somebody has been waiting for him he
gets inside the building and is welcomed
by xiao by a guardian who disguises
himself as a girl he's then brought to a
room where he meets a beautiful ghost
yingling who is able to reveal the
quality and color of the elixir yinglian
is very attractive and attempts to
seduce the innocent zai gene however the
clemont knows the limit and refuses to
kiss her
he attempts to leave but yinglian keeps
teasing him when she tries to approach
zygin she's thrown away by the spell
casted by the old priest previously
yinglian pretends to be okay but she
keeps being thrown away every time he
turns around
the beautiful ghost is so desperate
because she couldn't get close to him
however
zygin already falls in love with the
yingling and states that he will marry
her
yingling tries to scan his whole body
but sees nothing because he is protected
after he falls asleep she informs
xiaobai that she saw nothing and
couldn't reveal the elixir color
on the other side yinglian is tortured
because she couldn't finish her mission
it turns out that her soul is kept in
the lotus and the guardian has full
control over her
long story short
zygin and xiaobai arrive at a city where
the imperial examination will be
conducted
there the clemont keeps asking people
about his brother darren night arrives
and all the candidates are registering
themselves to the examination they are
examined thoroughly to ensure nobody is
keeping a secret note the next day all
candidates enter the room and prepare
themselves for the exam
the exam begins and it continues until
midnight
suddenly a man claims that he sees
ghosts and distracts other candidates
causing him to be brought out of the
room a few moments later yinglian
appears and pulls xiaobai's soul out of
his body she tells him that the ghost of
the room will capture a bunch of
students souls including zai jeans she
adds that this will be the perfect time
for him to kill the clemont and obtain
the elixir
zygin's soul meets darren but he
suddenly turns into an evil ghost and
xiaobai comes to help him
they are then trapped and zygin is
brought to another dimension
wukxi reveals that darren failed too
many times in the exam and died in the
examination room
xiaobai is attacked by evil spirits
while darwin attempts to absorb
zhaijin's soul wuksi sacrifices itself
and emits a very bright light which
allows daoran to remember his past and
eliminates all the evil spirits before
disappearing darwin recognizes his
brother and tells him that xiaobai has
followed him all the way only to take
the elixir of the soul in his body shall
buy and zygin's souls return to their
bodies while eating the clemont forces
xiaobai to be honest with him and asks
him about the elixir of the soul he is
willing to give him the elixir but
xiaobai needs to help him free yinglian
the fox spirit then reveals the truth
behind the beautiful ghost she used to
be an orphan abducted by human traitors
and was sold as a prostitute she then
committed suicide and transformed into a
ghost who eats human hearts and sucks
their blood to preserve her beauty xin
finally ventured out to propose to
yinglian at first she refuses the
proposal because she is a ghost and a
tree demon
however
the clemont insists that he still wants
to marry her which makes her flatter
she then betrays the foxes and runs away
with his hygiene xiaobai has been
waiting for them on the bridge yinglian
has a good intention to save him from
xiaobai but zhaijin doesn't seem to be
want to be saved as he keeps protecting
the fox spirit unfortunately the demon
frog stabs ying lian from behind
the dying ying lian brings xin with him
and runs away however it is too late to
save her
before disappearing junglian expresses
her gratitude to the innocent scholar
zygin's heart is broken into pieces
because she is the only thing that
matters in his life
he's very angry and is very disappointed
in xiaobai because he has been lying all
the time
feeling guilty xiaobai attempts to stab
himself with the knife but suddenly a
portal appears and sucks him into it
turns out that the old priest has been
observing xiaobai and prevents him from
doing something silly
the chief reveals that the kid who saved
his life was zygin in his previous life
he adds that the white elixir was
planted inside the kid's body and must
be taken by xiao by himself long story
short xin attempts to find xiaobai and
meets him in the bamboo forest he
apologizes and zygin sacrifices himself
to give the elixir to his best friend
it turns out that zhaijin was talking to
the guardian who disguises himself to be
shaobai
the guardian also states that it is not
a white elixir and says that all his
effort was useless the real xiaobai is
very angry and attempts to kill the
guardian
they engage in a fight where the
guardian suddenly transforms into a
six-tailed fox
he is too strong for shaobai and he is
beaten to death before dying he recalls
his memories with zai jin and touches
the black elixir
suddenly its color turns into white and
xiaobai transforms into a nine-tailed
fox in this form he manages to be his
guardian easily and attempts to kill him
however
he remembers about zai jin who wished
him to be a good fox he changes his mind
and the six-tailed fox runs away long
story short zygin is revived and then
walks back to his home where he meets
his grandmother
someday he meets an injured small fox
and decides to bring it home it turns
out that xiaobai traded his immortality
with xaigen's life and is transformed
into that small fox
since then zaigen and the fox have lived
together happily on the other side the
guardian is captured and locked up in a
painting because he is the main culprit
behind the death of the junior students
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out
thank you for watching